there is a place to far place from here
called China have you heard about this
place communist China and right now guys
they are instituting something called a
credit score the Chinese credit score
system it is happening it's particularly
happening in these 15-minute cities that
they're building in and it is completely
the direction we are moving in at least
the blue states are moving in
and that is exactly what Anthony fauci
wants he wants a bunch of people you can
break so they end up like this a good
school brings benefits that people with
low scores lose rights the cinema names
and shames people considered
untrustworthy Plastering their details
even their addresses across big screens
it's a matter of principle those people
have to be condemned those people aren't
honest so they have to pay the price
it's only right to pay your debts you
have to Blacklist those that don't
court has created a book list for
so-called bad citizens those whose
ratings have dropped to zero on it are
companies but also 23 million people to
date
among them is this journalist Liu who he
got a little too close to uncovering
corruption among high-profile party
members after being sued for defamation
by the subject of a story he'd written
he was blacklisted they only realized
when he tried to buy a train ticket and
was told he was banned from traveling
that tells me I'm still on The Blacklist
punished because he's been branded
untrustworthy by the state
once you're blacklisted you can no
longer get a bank loan start a business
buy an apartment
or even send your children to a private
school
you who is among a tiny minority of
people who have dared to criticize a
system which some are calling a digital
dictatorship
I worry because I think many people like
me will be deprived of individual
freedoms
and all of us will live with
restrictions of one kind or another
does it seem like too much of a jump to
go from fauci who literally said he
wanted to break people
to what is going on in China right now
I don't think it does we are all walking
around with this device and once they
can say you can't get on that train you
can't leave your 15-minute City you
can't pay that person this you can't get
a loan at this bank or even open up an
account etc etc you can see where all
this is going they want a bunch of
mindless drone slaves they want a bunch
of non-playable characters and PCs
[Music]
foreign